foreign
the best thing for your work ethic is to
have a rest Yes actually that's one I've
started something along the lines of the
key to a great work ethic is having a
great rest ethic so this idea of I think
goofing off
wasting time
sabbatical sabbaths taking a Sabbath
are all essential to to the creative
life they're just they're just
absolutely it's almost like sleep
you just have to do it and it does it by
re rejuvenating you and shifting your
perspective
by releasing you from I mean there's
just so many things that it works on
and most I think
for me and my own experience are the the
best things that I've done
came after you know taking shifting it's
like the clutch when you're shifting you
want to put the clutch in right
otherwise you just kind of grind so I
think it's really valuable and and again
not just like every seven years which is
a technical sabbatical but like Sam is
like vacations
but more importantly time off and
goofing off and I think I find that the
young people believe it or not the ones
that I am associated with don't Goof Off
enough they go right from college
in their first job and that's like
no yeah
there were people that wired they came
right from college and after seven years
they were still there it's like
I sit down like why are you here
you should not be here when was the last
time you goofed off or wasted time yeah
yeah and so
so no I'm a big believer so imagine the
rest of management must love that I was
the management no were you the only
management we don't have to be labor the
point
why did some people quit last week oh
I've been talking to that Kelly so I
think it's essential and so that your
your question of like well
this is why I love you it's like yeah
give me some practical stuff about how
to take a sabbatical
or just what might it look like right
for for someone who I mean let's
personalize it like for me yeah what
might a sabbatical look like what would
you consider the sort of minimal viable
duration and like what would make it a
sabbatical versus me just being in a
foreign Locale thinking about the usual
stuff so it's interesting because my
wife's both of her companies she's been
at she was at Jenny's like for 30 years
and she said 23andMe now
well generally had a sabbatical program
an official one it was six weeks every
six years which is basically a European
Vacation yeah right an annual vacation
so
I think six weeks is probably like for
me like the minimum for a sabbatical but
man it could be very effective in six
weeks
for me like doing art is something I
like
you know in the old days you used to
have to like professors would get
sabbaticals and they would do their own
project that they were working on or go
to a school somewhere or have a visiting
appointment
you know travel is a very very common
one
for you
I think you know your effort right now
to to work in animation and stuff
I guess the general pattern is you want
something that's different in the
structure and Rhythm from what you
normally do and so our Temptation those
of us who like to make things is to make
something different but that's not
really
sabbatical we're kind of in the same
Rhythm we're learning and so it's sort
of like you want to go in a different
direction and
I did sabbatical ones where I just read
books and it was like literally that's
all I'm gonna do I'm gonna get up in the
morning I'm gonna read books
and I'm not gonna do anything else and
that was really different from my normal
behavior
but incredibly powerful and by the end I
just had I went to travel because I had
it you know it's just like blew my gas
because it had to go but that sabbatical
of like only reading books and reading
books all day long and I could read
almost like about a average of a about a
book a day because some books are really
short and some were really long but my
the synapse associations that you get
from reading book after book after book
you begin to think that it's they're all
talking to each other the authors yeah
it's like they're talking about the same
thing they must have known about each
other you know it's impossible but you
have this sense of this all knitting
together yeah saturation yeah so I think
the the recipe is to have a different
Rhythm and a different mode than you
normally have